- On a eu une vie remplie.
- Bien remplie, oui.
- Théo Wouters et Roger Thib
sont ensemble depuis
un demi-siècle.
THÉO WOUTERS
- On était, depuis le début,
convaincus de rester ensemble
pour le reste de nos jours.
C'est ça.
(applaud
- Le 18 juillet 2002,
il y a 20 ans, ils ont
officialisé leur union.
Une journée mémorable,pour plust
conjoints unis civilement.- C'éc
qu'on a réalisée ce jour.
Avant leAvant leAvant le mariagu
beaucoup de harcèlement
depuis pdepuis pdepuis pdepuis ,
dans notre voisinage et...
pour nous, c'était très
important d'avoir t d'avoir t d,
finalement.
- Des droits garantis
par la loi 84.
Aucune abstention.
(applaud(applaud(applaud(applau)
- Et qui ont permis à Théo et
Roger de combattre l'homophobie
dont ils étaient victimes.
- C'était épouvantable,
épouvantable. 10 ans dans la
peur. On a eu du feu sur
notre maison et un gros caillou
dans notre auto.
PATRICK DESMARAIS,
président, Fondation Émergence
- C'est sûr que pour une
personne aînée, ça devient
très lourd au niveau émotif,
et ça il faut le dénoncer.
Ce qui est intéressant
re à constater,
c'est qu'on a des outils
maintenant au Québec.- S'il a dt
n'a pas pour autant disparu,
mais le couple a surmonté
l'adversité en donnant vie
à un jardin, bâti pierre
par pierre.
ROGER THIBAULT
- Ça représente tout, tout,
tout, tout. Ça représente
la vie. Ça représente...
je sais pas.
- Beaucoup de plaisir
à faire le jardin.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ça, c'est toutes les photos
de notre mariage.
- Ce sentiment de fierté,
ils le vivent à nouveau
devant les photos de leur union.
- Ça c'est le gâteau.
- 20 ans après, Théo cult
encore sa passion pour la
haute couture et la peinture.
availle, quand sa santé
le lui permet, sur un nouveau
livre racontant l'histoire
d'un jardin de ville où chaque
espèce s'épanouit en liberté.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-C